[موسيقى]
في هذا الريف ثوره جديده تحط رحالها للتو
رياح هبت من المدينه على هذه الحقول
فاينعتها بالجديد واي جديد انها الثوره
الرقميه هذا الشاب المزارع ليس بصدد اللعب
على هاتفه الذكي بل انه يقوم بالضبط
الاعدادات لتوصيل الغذاء الى ماشيته
هنا في هذا المطبخ نجد البرسيم والقش هنا
مثلا سراج الذره وهنا سيلاج العشب
يعرف الروبوت موقع الحيوانات فاذا كانت
البقره حلوبا سيعطيها الكميه اللازمه اذا
كانت غير ذلك سيقدم لها حصتها الخاصه بها
روبوتات في خدمه ابقار انطوان على مدار
الساعه وطيله ايام السنه
الابقار هنا في حريه تامه تاكل متى شاءت
وعندما تشعر برغبه في الحرب تذهب الى
الروبوت الالي
يجعلها هذا الامر على احسن ما يرام
انطوان اخذ على عاتقه مهمه توجيه المزرعه
العائليه نحو انتاج الالبان بالطريقه
الرقميه
[موسيقى]
انا لا اتخيل نفسي في سن الخمسين كما حصل
مع والدي واعمامي وعماتي وقد استنفذت كل
جهدي في عمليه الحرب الشاقه طبعا نوعيه
الحياه اليوم القت بظلالها على عالم
الزراعه
حداثه لها ثمنها طبعا من اجل اله الحلب
فقط انفقت عائله موريس مئه الف يورو
تكلفه هذا التغيير والخوف من المجهول
يمثلان عائقا امام ولوج الزراعه عوالم
التكنولوجيات الحديثه
في مدينه شارتر بالشمال الفرنسي يبدو ليك
مزارعا مثل باقي المزارعين لديهما صراحه
من الحبوب تمتد على مساحه 320 هكتارا لكن
نشاطه الاساسي يتم على مستوى الحاسوب يجمع
ملايين البيانات
[موسيقى]
انه شغفي بمهنتي شغفي بالرياضيات شغفي
بالهندسه الزراعيه وفيزيولوجيا النبات لقد
ولدت مرتديا حذائي حاملا حاسوبا في يده
الهدف بالنسبه لي هو التخطيط والتنبؤ
يجسد هذا المزارع فكره اصليه في فرنسا
وتمكن من تصدير افكاره الى الخارج هذا
مثلا لم استطع القيام به في فرنسا بينما
في رومانيا استطعت تحقيقه في غضون ثلاث
سنوات استنادا الى الصور الاقمار الصناعيه
نقدم معلومات للمزارعين وادوات فهم
تساعدهم على اتخاذ القرارات الصائبه نعمل
في رومانيا مع سبع مزارع تتراوح مساحتها
بين هكتارين الى 15 الف هكتار
خلافا لليوكي استطاع البعض تحقيق افكاره
هنا على الارض الفرنسيه
مرحبا
احضرت لك الكاميرا سنضعها على هذا المكان
المزارع قام بتطوير كاميرا متصله بالنت
لمراقبه نظام الري
انها متصله بالانترنت حاليا بامكانك
التاكد
ممتاز حاول تحريكها
هبه كبيره لا تكلف الشابه عن التنقل
للتاكد من ان كل شيء يسير على ما يرام
ركزوا كثيرا على الموقع الاخر الذي يحتوي
على ادوات ريدون كاميرا اما هنا فاراقب عن
بعد لنفترض ان الادوات التكنولوجيه تسهل
عملنا لكن المزارع يواجه قيودا كثيره
ويعمل ضمن مساحات شاسعه من الاراضي هل ترى
الامر اسهل لست متاكدا من ذلك لكن عدد
الساعات وعبئ العمل ليس نفسهما
العالم الزراعي يتحول شيئا فشيئا والسوق
كذلك البعض يقتنص الفرصه لبلوغ الهدف
المرجوم
لقد نمت النباتات جيدا اجل لقد نمت جيدا
يزوران اليوم احد زبائنهما المتخصص في
زراعه البطيخ هذه النباتات ممتازه نرى
جيدا كيف اينعت اما هذه فقد اضرتها حشره
المن
قبل اربع سنوات قام هذان الشبان اللذان
ينحدران من عائله مزارعه بانشاء سوق للخضر
والفواكه عضويه ورقميه مئه بالمئه تجمع
موزعين ومنتجين ناشئين
المزارع هو حرفي قبل كل شيء نحاول اليوم
من خلال التكنولوجيا الرقميه توفير حلول
مختلفه وطرقا مختلفه في العمل حتى يستفيد
منها الجميع بالطبع
الفكره قام بتطويرها هنا في مدينه شطودان
في حاضنه الشركات الناشئه هذه المخصصه
لزراعه الغد
لدي اخبار جيده لك
لقد وفرت لك الخيار حتى شهر اغسطس
الهدف من منصتهم الالكترونيه تسهيل
المعاملات المتعلقه بالمنتجات العضويه وفق
اسعار مناسبه تكون الفكره في توفير جميع
المعلومات الخاصه بمنتوج معين بشكل اني
وبالمخزون المتوفر له لدى المنتج انيا
كذلك مع تحديد السعر المبدئي الذي نضيف
اليه تكلفه النقل حتى يكون كل شيء واضح
بالنسبه لزبائننا حول السعر النهائي
ادوات لتوفير الوقت وزياده الربح وتخفيف
اعباء العمل اليومي ركائز اساسيه يستند
اليها الشغوفون بعوالم الزراعه الرقميه
بالنسبه اليهم المستقبل بين يدي
التكنولوجيا